[Music]
[Applause]
uh Jeff Benedict New York Times
best-selling author and the new book is
Lebron and uh he's written quite a few
books wrote on Tiger Woods we'll talk
about some of the other books that he's
written when did you come to I guess
that decision that you were going to
write about LeBron James the decision
yeah no no pun intended uh can we uh
move your mic there a little bit to you
there you go so
when did you come to that realization
that you know what I think I'm ready to
write a book on LeBron it was shortly
after finishing tiger
and uh the Patriots had just lost the
Super Bowl of the Eagles
and I was actually pitching to my
publisher the dynasty that's the book I
intended to do next
and uh Simon Schuster really wanted me
to get try to get access in Foxboro
before
giving me a green light to do that book
and that's when the decision was made to
do LeBron but what do you start like
what do you do yeah so I've I've been
doing this a long time as you know Dan
and I have a process that I follow and
and so with LeBron
um I just I did what I always do which
is I start with a really deep dive and
create a timeline for the subject's life
so in LeBron's case it's it's 38 years
it's which is not long
and in a 38-year lifespan with LeBron I
came up with a timeline that was over a
hundred pages long when I got done
creating it it's um it's almost a third
the length of a book which is incredible
but the benefit of doing that is then
you have something you can look at
literally on paper and you can see the
what are the moments that you really
need to zero in on and explore and
expand for a reader things that they
don't know because there's there's all
these bright light moments in in
someone's life like LeBron that
everybody knows like when he was on the
cover of Sports Illustrated the first
time as the chosen one or when he won
you know when he made the decision to
leave and go to South Beach or when he
returned to Cleveland delivered the
championship you know those big moments
that everyone knows but the challenge of
biography is you need to fill the book
with things that people don't know
or else it's not worth reading and
that's what that that first sort of six
month period about is it's finding those
and then figuring out how you're going
to illuminate them on the page what was
the one that you went wow
there were actually a lot of them I mean
for example
you know
when I saw the first newspaper clip of
LeBron one of the things I did Dan in
the beginning was get subscriptions to
the Akron Beacon Journal and the
Cleveland Plain Dealer and I read every
single story that had ever been written
about LeBron the first thing I found was
a story that was like two paragraphs and
it was LeBron's first peewee football
game in Akron that was actually reported
in the paper and he scored like a few
touchdowns and I just thought wow this
is remarkable I a lot of people played
peewee football they're not in the
newspaper but you could almost see that
early that this kid was different than
everybody else and I thought the first
time he met Michael Jordan
really jumped out to me as a fascinating
moment because by that time LeBron had
agreed to keep a journal for this
up-and-coming magazine called slam and I
was reading all those journal entries
that LeBron wrote I thought it was
fascinating that he wrote a journal
people don't remember or know that
but he wrote a really great journal
entry after meeting Michael Jordan for
the first time and that happened in
Chicago in the summer between a
sophomore and junior year of high school
he was there playing in an AAU
Tournament Maverick Carter was coaching
him and they got invited in this
tournament in between games to go to
Jordan's gym Jordan's retired at this
point hasn't come back to play for the
Wizards yet and LeBron gets to go to the
gym where his Idol works out and after
that short visit the the guy who had
invited them said you know you ought to
come back at the end of the summer and
you can stay at my house and you could
work out at the gym LeBron gets
permission from his mom to do that he
comes back and he goes to the gym and
there's a bunch of guys from the NBA
like Jerry Stackhouse and Antoine Walker
all these guys that would come back in
the off season and work out at Jordan's
gym they're all there playing
and LeBron gets to go on the floor and
run with them I mean think about it he's
going into his junior or high school
he's running around with these guys
and I called that chapter a different
floor because when LeBron got on the
floor same size as his high school floor
but doesn't look it with these Giants
when they extend their arms play defense
there's no passing Lanes there's no
driving Lanes anymore but the really
important thing was first of all these
guys saw this kid could actually create
his own shots and score against them
as an incoming High School junior
and then even more importantly when
LeBron was leaving that last day of
being there when they're walking out of
Hoops
Jordan pulls in
and that's the moment where LeBron and
Michael meet for the first time and this
is really important because Michael
invites him back inside and by this time
Michael has decided he is going to come
back and play but he hasn't announced it
yet so the public doesn't know it he
knows it he takes the LeBron inside his
private gym and they talk for about 15
minutes he doesn't give him any advice
but he gives him his cell phone number
and this is to me it's a pivotal moment
for LeBron James because the next day
LeBron goes to his first day of his
junior year of high school and when he
shows up he's got Michael's number in
his back pocket and if you fast forward
five months Grant Wall from Sports
Illustrated is going to walk into
LeBron's locker room
at the high school and he's got about 15
seconds to pitch LeBron on the idea of
letting him profile him for the magazine
and his pitch is I know you're going to
Cleveland tonight with your friends to
watch Michael play against the Cavaliers
can I drive you and that chapter is
called get in the car because LeBron
makes a decision in that moment without
consulting any adults or his parents
to get in Grant Wall's car and when they
get there that night Michael comes out
after the game to talk to LeBron in the
in the tunnel and Grant Wall is
observing LeBron talk to Michael
like a friend
it's only been since the previous summer
that they met but Michael now knows
LeBron's mother knows her by name asks
how she's doing LeBron tells him she's
down in New Orleans
and and Grant's just going wow look at
the way this kid he is a kid is carrying
on with the greatest athlete of our time
to me when you see those kind of moments
those are shaping instances where you're
seeing the growth and evolution of a
young man who's going to become the next
great
I immediately thought when you were
telling the story that Michael the
businessman
is looking at LeBron James and investing
in LeBron James to be part of the Jordan
brand
is that reading too much into it and and
not acknowledging that maybe there is a
mentorship involved in this I think
there's a couple things going on here
that Nike at this moment in time when
when LeBron and Michael intersect
Sunny Vaccaro has the inside track to
Mike uh to LeBron he's been recruiting
LeBron to come to Adidas and he's ahead
of Nike at this point but Nike has
Michael and so there is that element of
it but
Michael was never like this
active recruiter okay he didn't need to
be that's the thing Sunny is really
competing against Phil Knight you know
he's left Nike there's
um a little bit of acrimony
Sonny got in early one of my favorite
scenes in the whole book when you talk
about finding something you didn't know
I did not know
how sunny established the relationship
with LeBron and Gloria James to me it's
a far more fascinating story and I love
the movie air but but Sunny didn't have
a relationship with Michael Jordan when
Michael Jordan was in high school or
college he built a relationship with
LeBron when LeBron was a kid he was he
went to Akron Gloria James went to
California and had dinner at Sonny's
house LeBron went to San Francisco or
Oakland and actually auditioned I I call
it an audition because to me it reminded
me of a child star that wants to get on
Broadway you know performing in front of
Stephen Sondheim to find out if they're
going to get the part I mean LeBron did
that and everyone in the gym all the
coaches from LeBron's high school team
and his AAU coaches they're all nervous
because they know Sunny is like the
Godfather of sneakers he has that much
power he's sitting in the bleachers like
an audience of one to watch LeBron play
one time and by the way he didn't do
that for Kobe he didn't do that for
Michael he did it for LeBron and after
about 10 minutes
Sonny got up and walked out
just didn't even say goodbye to anybody
in the middle of the game just left got
a cab with his wife and left and
everyone in the gym thought oh no this
is a disaster but on the ride to the
airport his wife Pam finally says to
Sonny what's what and he goes I've I've
never seen
a player like that he was so impressed
it was in that moment he decided Adidas
has to get him
and of course Sunny is the reason why
Michael Jordan went to Nike because of
his relationship with Mike's uh mom
we're talking to Jeff Benedict New York
Times best-selling author the new book
is LeBron
I'm always curious about how we don't
Embrace LeBron like we Embrace Steph
Curry and we Embrace Patrick Mahone
there's certain athletes we embrace
why is LeBron not embraceable
well I think first of all a lot of
people do Embrace him but
it feels like half of the country
doesn't and or half of the NBA fans
but I think we have to go back a little
bit in time but we Embrace Jordan yes
but here that's part of the problem when
you're coming in as the declared
successor to Michael right away that's a
huge disadvantage because Michael has
this huge deeply embedded following he
transformed basketball he was bigger
than the game he's loved beyond the
borders of the United States He is that
mythical of a figure LeBron comes in as
the guy who's supposed to basically
replace him not just succeed him but
replace him that's tough he didn't ask
for that it was put on him
early in his career and I'm talking
about the Cleveland years I think
LeBron was largely admired I mean he
wasn't controversial in the Cleveland
years when he did what he did to Detroit
in game five I mean as things like that
were happening the the NBA world was
embracing him more and more and more
because you just couldn't help but be
impressed with what he was doing with a
team that had no business competing with
teams like the Pistons but for the fact
they had LeBron then everything changes
when he said he was taking his talents
to South Beach now it's now it's not
just embrace it's everybody in the
league against LeBron except for people
who live in Miami and it took him going
back to Cleveland to start to reverse
that and then LeBron just did something
very bold that no one else in his
position would do because it was so
risky which was he stepped into politics
and he did it in a he started doing it
during the Obama years and that was
actually one of my favorite parts of the
book to write because when you
people forget that LeBron's first brush
with politics was heading into the
Beijing Olympics when shezewsky was the
coach Kobe was on that team people
forget that it was the same playoffs
where LeBron went to town on Detroit in
game five that same playoffs season is
when LeBron was hammered mercilessly for
declining to sign a letter that his
teammate Ira noobly had put together and
all the rest of the Cavaliers signed
calling out China for their human rights
violations LeBron didn't sign it
all the major media in the United States
hit LeBron pretty hard for that then
game five happened and all that went
away then a year later the Olympics came
and it all came back and LeBron went to
the Olympics with Kobe and they did a
press conference where LeBron basically
said you can't mix politics and sports
that was the summer of 08. Barack Obama
was running for president and Jay-Z is a
has agreed to do these benefit concerts
for
candidate Obama and he asks LeBron who
invites LeBron to do the last one with
him in Cleveland and LeBron does it and
he gets up on stage in a packed house
and he endorses Obama and he encourages
the whole place to vote for him that's
his coming out into politics in 08
over the next eight years Barack Obama
did more to recruit NBA players into the
White House not just when they won
championships people like Magic Johnson
were going to the White House just to
help Obama with his domestic agenda and
LeBron did that he did it with the
Affordable Care Act LeBron learned a lot
in the Obama years in those eight years
and by the time those eight years are
over
he's endorsed Hillary Clinton he
campaigns for Hillary Clinton
and then he starts to take on Trump when
Trump gets elected and and I think when
he did that
now it's a forget Sports oh yeah this is
totally different and so when you ask
that big question about LeBron he is a
much more complex character individual
than most athletes who come along in
America he didn't start that way but he
has become that over the years
if you were going
um if I compared tiger to LeBron
is is there anything that would jump out
that they are this together or they're
not even close to being the same people
there they're not close I mean the one
thing they have in common is
they I I would say that tiger
LeBron
and Tom Brady
are the the three greatest male athletes
that America has produced in this
century
in the 21st century they have passed
everyone else because
they approach their Sports as a craft
they are more disciplined
and they have
longevity you know you you just don't
see LeBron started doing this when he
was 18. the fact that he catapulted from
high school to the pros and the moment
he arrived the moment he arrived he was
dominant I mean he didn't need a few
years to ramp up he was dominant in his
first game his first game and so LeBron
has been doing this for two decades at
the highest level and Tom and tiger were
the same way they were immediately
dominant and so I think that tiger and
LeBron have that in common but after
that they are very very different people
I'm glad you stopped in Jeff
congratulations on the success not only
this book but the other ones as well you
have Dynasty you also have the tiger a
book and it's LeBron it's available now
in bookstores online wherever books are
sold thank you Jeff we'll come back
we'll get to phone calls back after this